- This is "Kelly and Chrissy's
Ultimate Twitter Questionnaire".
- [Chrissy] Ooh, wow!
♪ It's Kelly's Ultimate
Twitter Questionnaire. ♪
- Get it, Jesse Collins.
- We need to do
a buddy comedy, I like that, together.
- All right, so here's what we do.
I'm going to hit this button
and a question, and it's fancy,
we've upgraded.
- It is.
- It lights up.
It's the second season Chrissy.
- I know!
- And a question, once we hit the button,
a question from Twitter
will pop up on our screen,
then Chrissy and I will give
a well-thought-out opinion
and flawless answer to that question.
We literally haven't seen these questions.
- So, here we go!
- Valid point, as ever.
- Yeah, well...
(both laughing)
So, you met your 18-year old self,
you're allowed to say three words.
What do you say?
(Kelly laughing)
- It'll work out.
(both laughing)
- Wait...
- I used to like, I mean, I
was just such a nervous
Nellie all the time,
I didn't know what I was
gonna do with my life,
I didn't know,
I didn't know what I wanted to do,
I didn't know if anyone liked me,
I didn't know if I got,
did good on this test,
I just never knew anything.
- That's so funny...
- I was so anxious.
- 'Cause people, I think,
perceive you as, like, so lovable
and, like, you're, you
were probably that girl.
- Oh, terrified all the time.
I wet the bed til I was, like, 16.
- Really?
- Yeah, truly so anxious.
- Wow!
- Yeah.